hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again we
have some interesting news to talk about
today Centurion gameplay of the new
up-and-coming rework that's going to be
live on the testing grounds as well as
the gladiator changes in the warlord
changes carousel death is coming back
and a whole heap of other [ __ ] was
always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribers we knew I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the patches in the leaks so if
you want to be kept up-to-date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner I never miss out on an update
definite stay subscribe to the channel
and with that my Twitter and disco tube
in the description down below and let's
get started
as I said carousel of death is live
again today I do believe carousel of
death is the 4v4 mode I believe dance of
death is the two-on-two
but carousel death is the 4 on 4 and
that should it gets really hectic if
you're playing on those arena Maps so if
you didn't want to play carousel of
death again you have to go try that out
also we finally have the news on who won
the emotes I'll be showing that on
screen for the emo contest basically as
you can see this is some really nice
sarcastic and waiting emote so I'm
totally cool with that you know
sometimes trying to hold that point and
I was really coming to capture your
point whether it be CA or be so you're
kind of just telling you need something
to kind of hold yourself off this one
dude was reading a book and getting
bored the other guy was just kind of
waiting it was really cool not too bad
but those emotes will eventually be in
the full game I don't think they're
going to be in the full game just yet
we'll probably have to of course make
the emo in-game and then eventually
release it later but for the actual
content of the week we have elite
outfits I'm not even gonna be [ __ ]
bothered to explain of what the hell
these names are so I'm just gonna show
it to you on screen and you could do it
yourself because I'm not gonna be able
to pronounce these but as stated we
finally have the info everybody wants
and that's the testing ground info so
the dev site is stated before it will be
Centurion gameplay gladiator changes and
warlord changes so there's not going to
be any gladiator or warlord gameplay to
kind of showcase how the moves look
in-game but there will be Centurion
gameplay for you cent means so as a
reminder of the testing grounds it is a
public test server on August 29th
you know download will be needed for
this and it will be in the events
playlist on the faction war map and all
platforms in all regions are available
so anybody can play this and if you have
orders or XP
you want from the testing grounds and
you want to keep your progression it
allows you to grind in place so that's
really cool too and phase one will be
starting from August 29th to September
12th they want players to share
feedbacks and if you can't find the
survey I'll try to link it in my videos
throughout the remainder of the test
server it won't be going live until that
day of the 29th of August so do not
worry if it's not in this video I'll try
to put it in the remainder of my videos
as we continue throughout the test
server because obviously making the
server is very important is because it
allows the developers to know what moves
are bad what moves are good and what
they should should keep and should and
keep in the rework when it fully comes
to launch but first up we have Centurion
mains you guys are out first since you
guys got a video first thing is that the
zone attack is now faint Abel on the
second and third hit in the chain so you
can do it twice if you totally need to I
really in my opinion would probably just
fainted on the second or maybe bait into
the third hit but in my opinion I feel
like fainting in the second isn't too
bad
charged heavies can now faint during the
unblockable state you can still commit
to the move and faint GB as well but you
can now faint and during the unblockable
state before you could only just faint
before it turned unblockable but now of
course you could faint during that along
for a fuckload more mix-ups making
cinterion a lot more scarier speaking of
more scary stuff his second and third
light in his chain attacks are now 500
m/s so if we do light light light that
second and third light are gonna be 500
allowing you to do just a little bit
more damage and probably won't get
blocked on the first attempt next up is
that they made charged heavies not
guarantee the jab anymore but the jab
can now be fainted this allows players
to stop being put into cutscenes and but
still allows the player to get potential
damage and mix-ups basically meaning now
if you get cutscene it's your fault and
you couldn't basically meaning if you
got cutscene it's your fault because you
coulda dodged it obviously the Centurion
can now feint that into you know a GB
and stuff like that but still it still
allows for a lot more potential damage
and mix-ups without gearing without
giving them that guaranteed damage from
the cutscene I think I'm ok with this
and then the last thing is that you can
now chain light into GB
I didn't know if this was the thing
before but he was just going way off on
it during the gameplay I'm pretty sure
you couldn't have just done light into
jab light in a jab I don't think that
ever existed but yeah the jab of course
guarantees a light I feel like this is
an up-and-coming infinity-combo not
really sure if this is a good idea
because the way that he was doing the
light and the jab and the light in the
jab
if the jab guarantees a light then that
light is gonna follow up with a jab and
I feel like that's just going to be back
and forth I maybe I'm just [ __ ] but
I'm pretty sure that's what that means
but once again we don't need to complain
about these changes just yet that's why
it's in the testing ground so no need to
call for a nerf or a buff as just seeing
in the gameplay test it out in the
testing grounds show it off in the
survey let the developers know what's
wrong and what's good so they can keep
it or get rid of it before the live
servers next up is for gladiator and as
I stated gladiator will not have
gameplay same as warlord but we'll get
into his info right away
first up gladiators reflux guard is now
1,100 milliseconds which is on par with
every single character about [ __ ]
time
they added forward movement to the
skewer during the strikes and fainting
as well so you can now feint G be a lot
easier it was a little bit hard to feint
G be some opponents because they would
just dodge away or completely dodge roll
away so now with that added movement it
should be a lot easier to feint G be the
opponent with skewer which is really
nice the 2nd and the 3rd and the 4th
lights in the chain have now been
changed I would have just removed these
[ __ ] things straight up as I've
stated multiple times in my streams but
they decided to keep it and for those
changes the 2nd to 3rd and the 4th
change light from the top are gonna be
433 milliseconds and it's from the side
are gonna be 466 so basically roughly
around the same types of speed but it's
about 33 milliseconds difference
hopefully this won't be fast enough for
a light spin but I'm still cool with it
and lastly the toast AB is now going to
be 600 milliseconds when the opponent is
out of stamina as opposed to 800 which
is always beautiful so now the toast
that is even faster I love that for
warlord his live attacks are enhanced
and which means they're not stopped on
block they have increased range the top
light opener is 18 damage
set of 17 the sidelight opener is 15
instead of 14 and the top life finisher
is now 18 instead of 20 heavy attack
finishers have the uninterruptible
stance as they usually do but if pop
rocks at 300 milliseconds as opposed to
400 so it's going to be happening a lot
quicker and the full block stab
follow-up move from the full block
stance missed a few characters on
certain occasions so they readjusted the
tracking on the move to make sure that
it hit the opponent necessary so yeah
those are gonna be the changes
personally I'd the developers partially
said that this would be and this
wouldn't be all the changes I believe
they said this would be some of the
changes I really hope it is some of
those changes because there's a lot of
different things that gladiator at least
in my experience
gladiator needs it for his character I
mean for first up heavy light Shane
would do wonders for him but there's a
lot of different moves that gladiator
could use in his kit and not just these
I mean these are nice of course a reflex
card is the best thing I've ever [ __ ]
heard in my life but I feel like that
could be changed and I mean I feel like
just that isn't going to be enough to
boost this character up seeing is these
the three characters that we have here
for these works are basically bottom
three at this point who knows
they said they kind of did say that it
was some so hopefully it is just some of
the moves and not everything if they do
come out with a blog post or something
detailing all of that I will get you on
that next video as soon as I can so that
everybody knows what exactly is
happening yeah guys that's gonna be the
end of it so hopefully you guys did
enjoy it like uh like I said let me know
your comment and let me know your
thoughts on these works in the comments
below like I said just take this with a
grain of salt this stuff could be gone
in like three weeks because it might
actually be terrible and the testing
arounds then it will be removed from the
live servers but just as fate at face
value without playing just kind of your
thoughts let me know what you guys think
of course but obviously give your full
detailed thoughts in that survey when I
do link those coming next week and
throughout the entire phase because we
want to make sure that these reworks are
actually really good so definitely be
sure to link that [ __ ] I will get you
guys covered on that we had liked it if
you do enjoy guys subscribe for a new I
cover the informational site a foreigner
that being the balance changes the Year
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
I'm gonna be kept up today with
everything happening
the world of foreigner I never miss out
on an update that first day subscribe
the channel or the guys have a greater
sterday they could watching the video of
peace out and then we know your thoughts
[Music]
you